hey guys so I'm going to get AC AC test
right now stands for coronary artery
calcification scoring test this is one
of the absolute best test to predict not
just cardiovascular health
but mortality rates from all deaths it's
incredible so I wanted to get a test and
we're just gonna see what shows up but
it measures the calcification in the
coronary artery which is the main blood
flow to the heart so let's let's see
what happens
hey guys I'm going to an event in DC and
I wanted to quickly just look at my test
resort results yesterday I had a CA C
tests and calcium actually it's a
coronary artery calcium test and I know
I'm driving but I'm looking at the road
okay so I'm not looking at you guys so
just that's my justification this
coronary artery calcium test is the best
test to measure
mortality rates not just from heart
attacks from all mortality and so it's
one of the it's way better than
cholesterol because if you have calcium
in your arteries it's a serious serious
situation and today on my show this guy
called in from New York and his calcium
scoring test was over 1,500
I mean if it's over a thousand it's a
very very dangerous okay so you don't
want even to be over 400 you want to be
it habit like 200 less and a lot less so
we're gonna look at its downloading
right now and see what it says here okay
I gotta wait till I stop so yeah so you
go into this it's a cat scan you lay
down they put these EKG little sticker
little sticky things on you and you it
doesn't take long it's like five minutes
and then they they scan you it's not as
much radiation as most things but if
there's some but it's one of the best
scores so let's just see what it says
here
oh shoot
now I'm just kidding now I got a I got a
score of zero zero
that's really good guys that's actually
that's the ideal scene zero I love it so
there is absolutely zero calcium in my
arteries of the heart okay because they
didn't just measure the corner they
measured all the different areas so this
is very exciting well good
don't have to worry about that so if
your score is zero that means that you
have some you don't have any damage in
the arteries well of course I've been
doing this for a long time so if it even
showed up anything I would be surprised
so good got the test I got the test
results in them I'm happy about that
and nothing to worry about so I would
highly recommend you guys get this test
it's called coronary artery calcium test
and even if it shows positive for
anything don't be too alarmed because
you can improve it over time by keeping
your insulin low that's the that's the
key so stay on keto in a minute fasting
and then you want to do like one every
if it's hi doing every two months until
it goes down you want to see a trend
going lower and lower and lower it's
good feedback to know what you're doing
is getting your body healthy hey guys in
this video we're going to talk about
something very very very important and
very interesting it's called the
coronary artery calcium score okay first
of all what is the coronary artery well
it's the main artery that supplies blood
flow to the heart and muscle so when you
have a heart attack it's really that
artery that becomes obstructed that
starves off oxygen in blood flow to the
heart muscle and it cramps and you get a
heart attack and you die
and since heart attacks are the number
one leading cause of death worldwide it
might be a good idea to know more about
this test so you can predict if you're
gonna have a problem so if we reverse
engineer a heart attack we take it one
step back we're gonna get a cramp okay
the cramp of the heart why because the
artery is not free-flowing there's
something obstructing it
there's plaquing there could be a clot
composed of cholesterol calcium and a
certain type of protein called fibrin
and a couple other things okay so it's
all just coming in there but everyone's
so hyper focused on cholesterol they're
trying to reduce cholesterol thinking
this is what's causing this no this is
the effect of something earlier so they
put you on a statin drug and start
shutting down on the body's ability to
produce cholesterol and then we create
all sorts of other problems
so the combination between this and this
is really a band-aid coming in to heal a
lesion or a damage the wall of the
arteries so you have inflammation
because there's damage and the inside
lining of the vessel okay and the reason
why there's damage is because there's
high levels of insulin behind that so
high insulin is the culprit
I have tons and tons of videos on this
I'll put a link down below to learn more
about this but if here if you have heart
problems okay if you want to prevent
heart problems and you want to take
certain vitamins and this and that well
you also better handle this because if
this is not handled nothing's going to
work this is at the root the bottom
level cause of this chain reaction that
occurs that eventually give someone a
heart attack
so the coronary artery calcium test is a
direct measurement of the amount of
damage in the coronary artery okay so it
gives you insights of the person's past
life style of what they've been eating
what they've been doing it predicts
things a high score can occur with
normal cholesterol okay
the test is like a hundred dollars it
takes two seconds to do and you
definitely need to get it done you can
have normal cholesterol normal
triglycerides normal LDL normal blood
sugars and still have a lot of calcium
in the arteries and 50% of the time a
person will die of a heart attack
without any symptoms at all so you don't
want to just be surprised so the
emphasis should not be on the
cholesterol it should be on the calcium
as the most important predictor of heart
attacks so then the question is
why aren't more medical doctors
recommending this test well there's
several viewpoints one viewpoint is why
even do the test when we don't even know
what to do about it to actually correct
it so I'm like well that's because
you're using medical care to correct it
because you can't correct this with a
drug you can't correct this with
vegetable oils like from soy and corn
you can't correct this with healthy
grains okay now if you have a score of a
thousand that means your risk from
getting a heart attack is 10x okay
that's pretty high if your score is zero
your risk is extremely low chances are
you are not gonna die have a heart
attack you might die of getting hit by a
bus but not getting a heart attack if
your score is one to eighty you should
be concerned if your score is eighty one
to four hundred it's a pretty serious
situation
and you better start changing your
lifestyle if your score is greater than
four hundred it you better make sure you
have your will completely written out
and you better start studying how to
lower this really fast but you can
reverse it you can slow it down stop it
in Reverse it okay and improve it
greatly what's also interesting is that
this test can also predict risk from all
deaths not just heart attacks from
cancer from lung disease from kidney
disease so the next thing is your doctor
definitely request this test to see
where your baseline is thanks for
watching
hey if you enjoyed this video press
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated